Voici mon Draw my Life !
Oui, je sais j'arrive un peu après tout le monde,
mais le temps que les infos montent chez nous aussi... J'y peux rien !
Mais je voulais quand même vous raconter ma vie.
Moi je m'appelle Aristoclès.
Comme mon grand-père.
Si si !
Mais vous devez plus me connaître sous le nom de Platon.
C'est mon prof de gym qui m'a surnommé comme ça, à cause de ma carrure.
Oui, parce que Platon, ça veut dire "large" en grec ancien.
J'ai grandi à Athènes.
Heu...
Nan c'était pas comme ça...
Voilà.
Merci.
Et j'étais plutôt sportif.
Je faisais pas mal de lutte.
N... non c'est pas ça non plus... la lutte.
Voilà.
Voilà, je faisais de la lutte, voilà.
Et j'ai même gagné une médaille aux Jeux Olympiques.
Et ouais, ça existait déjà !
Ensuite je voulais être un bon citoyen, donc j'ai fait un peu de politique,
mais j'ai vite abandonné, parce que ceux qui dirigeaient étaient un peu excessifs.
Bref, ça m'a dégouté.
A côté de ça, je faisais de la poésie,
de la poésie héroïque.
Mais en comparant ma poésie à celle d'Homère, je la trouvais nulle.
Vous savez, celui qui a fait L’Iliade et l’Odyssée.
Du coup j'ai tout jeté au feu.
Ensuite, je me suis mis au genre tragique.
J'ai même fais une pièce et j'allais la faire jouer lorsque je l'ai rencontré.
J'avais 20 ans.
Il allait changer ma vie.
Il s'appelait Socrate.
Il était grand, fort et moche !
Il était très très moche.
Il avait 68 ans mais qu'est ce qu'il parlait bien !
De grandes phrases, le mot juste...
Il était très intelligent, il m'avait séduit.
Et à partir de ce moment, je laissais complètement tomber la tragédie pour faire comme lui : de la philosophie.
Socrate c'était un ancien hoplite : c'est des fantassin lourdement armés.
Qu'est-ce qu'il était puissant ! ~
Il me prenait souvent par derrière...- non !
Mais non ! Non non ! Non non non !
Il m’apprenait souvent par derrière ses discours...
Voilà, c'est ça que je voulais dire.
Il m'apprenait souvent par derrière ses discours, à me poser les questions justes.
J'étais devenu son disciple,
et je notais tout.
Tout ce qu'il me disait.
En fait, je suis un peu revenu a ma passion première : la tragédie,
en écrivant comme des pièces mais avec pour personnage principal : Socrate.
C'était chouette ! Mais malheureusement ça n'a duré que 8 ans...
Socrate a eu un procès et il a été condamné a boire du poison.
Il y avait beaucoup de ses disciples lors de sa mort,
mais pas moi, je n'étais pas là.
J'ai fait dire à un de mes personnages dans une de mes œuvres que j'étais malade.
Mais je crois que c'est la pire excuse qu'on puisse trouver...
Il me manque.
À ce moment là j'ai vite fui avec des potes à Mégare,
une ville où on peut se perdre facilement.
Puis je suis parti en Italie, en Libye...
et enfin en Égypte.
J'ai vu beaucoup de gens, beaucoup de paysages.
Et surtout, j'ai beaucoup écrit durant cette période.
Durant toute ma vie j'aurais quand même voyagé 12 ans en Méditerrané hein !
J'adore les voyages.
Après un retour à Athènes je suis finalement reparti en Italie.
Sicile la famille.
C'est comme ça qu'on dit non ?
C'est la que j'ai rencontré Dion.
C'est devenu un de mes meilleurs amis.
C'était le beau frère du tyran qui régnait là-bas.
Mais le voyage s'est mal passé.
Et j'ai été vendu en tant qu'esclave...
Pas hyper hyper cool comme situation j'vous avoue....
... hein, j'ai connu mieux.
Heureusement pendant la vente, un ami, Anniceris, m'a reconnu et m'a libéré !
J'ai eu beaucoup de chance !
Il m'a acheté pour 20 mines.
J'ai pas le taux de conversion mines/euro, mais avec 20 mines à l'époque on pouvait s'acheter un jardin !
J'étais de nouveau à Athènes.
Je voulais tout faire transmettre le savoir.
J'ai alors pu fonder l’Académie !
J'avais 40 ans.
Il y a eu pas mal de monde à l'Académie :
il y avait par exemple Pamphile, le maître d’Épicure ;
ou mon ami Xénocrate, ou encore Speusippe, mon neveu.
Ça se passait super bien, il y avait plein de gens.
Il y avait même des femmes, vous vous rendez compte pour l'époque ?
Et puis il y a eu Aristote.
J'ai pas eu une relation évidente avec lui.
En fait, certes il était intelligent, mais je sais pas, il était très superficiel.
Il faisait vachement attention à ses habits, ses chaussures...
Et puis il se coupait les cheveux, je comprenais pas trop l'intérêt.
Je l'appelais parfois mon poulain.
Parce que le poulain donne des coups de pied à sa mère quand il a bu son lait.
Et bah Aristote je le trouvais ingrat comme le poulain.
Je suis pas sûr que poulain ait gardé la même signification aujourd'hui d'ailleurs..
Un jour j'avais 80 ans.
J'me promenais tranquillement, seul, lorsque Aristote m'a pris en embuscade avec des amis à lui.
Il a commencé à me poser une série de questions, pour se moquer de moi,
en abusant de ma vieillesse.
Pendant un temps je me promenais que dans mon jardin du coup.
Vous comprenez pourquoi je l'appelais mon poulain ?
Et puis un soir de la même année, je suis allé me coucher, et je ne me suis jamais réveillé.
J'ai vu d'en haut ce que la philosophie est devenue au fil des ans, au fil des siècles, au fil des millénaires,
et j'suis fier qu'elle puisse s'apprendre si facilement !
En puis maintenant tout me monde peux essayer de faire son académie !
En faisant des vidéos sur internet, par exemple.
D'ailleurs j'en connais un qui en fait des cool ! Et si j'étais là je m'abonnerais pour sûr.
Il a un ami qui dessine super bien
"Mec ça fait chelou quand même... 'fin moi j'vois pas Platon dire ça.
- Bah moi non plus mais pour te remercier je voulais que les gens aillent voir ta chaîne.
- Ha ok.
C'est sympa.
- Bah je t'en prie."
Il s’appelle Thomas Finas et il fait des animations sympa sur ses deux chaines :
Pipolatta et Tom&Ludo.
Tout est dans la description.
Bref, tant qu'il y aura des gens pour regarder ce genre de vidéos, la philosophie se cessera jamais d'exister.
Merci à vous.
Ah oui et si je vous ai pas parlé de femmes c'est pas que j'ai oublié hein.
C'est juste que je suis resté célibataire toute ma vie.
En tout cas si cette vidéo vous a plu, n’hésitez pas à la partager !
Bisous !